[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Applause]
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions it's the ramsey show where
debt is dumb cash is king and the paid
off home mortgage has taken the place of
the bmw
as the status symbol of choice this is
the place where we take your calls about
your relationships your boundaries your
career your money your job and your life
it's a free call and some say the advice
is worth exactly what you pay for it
triple eight eight two five five two two
five rachel cruz ramsey personality
number one best-selling author is my
co-host today as we open up this hour
though we had a good friend drop by
and has a new book out and so we ask him
to sit in for a couple segments and tell
us about it
the one and only tim tebow is with us
welcome my friend thank you so much so
honored to be here uh first time i've
been in the new facilities it's
incredible it's awesome so you guys are
just crushing it and doing so much for
so many people thank you for having me
and just thank you for what you're doing
as well well thank you brother for those
of you that uh don't know tim and i've
only watched him from afar uh he is one
of the ones that is actually who he
projects himself to be
you know what i'm saying i mean aka the
real deal he's the real deal he's the
real thing and so if you thought that
that was tim tebow that is actually him
we were just back in the green room a
few minutes ago hanging out having lunch
and
he's the same guy so uh we're honored to
have you sir honor we've been able to do
a few things together over the years and
uh this new book mission possible go
create a life
that counts
um man you
you have about six missions going at all
times in your life you're you gotta
you're a driven guy a crusader in a
whole bunch of different areas at one
time so this is perfect what's the
driving force to do a book called
mission possible encouragement
encouragement and people's worth their
value and their purpose in life and why
i wanted the right mission possible was
because i wanted to encourage people one
when you you know you have a mission
means you know you have purpose and two
when you know it's possible you have
encouragement for endurance and for
stamina in your race and i would
encourage people that it's not
impossible
to have a life that counts
we get to we get to have a life that
truly counts god has made that possible
i believe he's given every single one of
us purpose he's given every single one
of us a mission a mission means a task
or a job someone is given to do and
actually the origin of the world means
to sin and i believe every single one of
us has been sent here for a mission for
a purpose for a plan and that is
possible possible means to be able that
mission we are able to accomplish that
mission to truly make our life count and
you know so many people are going to say
well you know what i i think what i need
to really run after is money fame and
power status and all these other things
and i'm here to say you could have all
those things and you could still be
empty and not really have anything right
be careful if you run after them we
might catch them you might catch them
but you know what if you run after
purpose and worth and value in meaning
you might catch them too you might catch
them and i believe when you do that
you're going to truly have a life that
counts so what i think is interesting is
like what you just contrasted right
there right of like what the world what
you feel like would fill you up you know
that's right power fame money all of
these things right it's going to make me
feel better versus going after almost
this
not tangible side of life of
value purpose having something that you
is so much different so talk about that
contrasting because you've kind of but
that's god's economy right is we
actually think
when we give we have less that's not
true when we give we actually have more
in god's economy and what's crazy is
that science and studies actually back
that up we talk about one study from the
university i know they're miami so it's
hard to mention them but we can you have
that nasty little
orange tee thing over there whatever
we'll let it let it go it's fine that's
what grace is for guys honestly it's
totally fine
that's exactly right i know but but we
talk about the this study and it's
fascinating because the the this um this
these groups write down one thing every
day they're grateful for and then other
groups write down things that they don't
like and then there's different groups
in here and the group that would write
down you think it's nothing right one
day write down or every day write down
one thing you're grateful for it had a a
biochemical positive change
in their life in their body from the
inside out just by writing down one
thing they're grateful for so gratitude
changes your life but also there's
another study about a helper's eye when
you choose to actually serve and give
selflessly to other people you also have
a biochemical positive reaction from the
inside out and it's crazy wait a second
to actually do these things to choose to
be grateful to choose to help
not only do i have an emotional response
but i actually have a chemical response
for the better that's crazy and you live
longer
and you have a higher quality of life in
the process no doubt rachel's got a
gratitude journal that we put out right
contentment journal content but
gratitude's one of the steps to
contentment because it is it's like when
you're
able to have peace with where you're at
we're gonna put you i'm like there's
there's a level of power there that that
brings there's gratitude is that first
step and i feel like one of the things
that um that we're fighting right now
and we're talking about it before the
show right now is comparison and why
would you
literally another study com came out
that said twelve percent of our daily
thoughts are spent on some form of
comparison when you are spending your
life comparing yourself against other
people what you're really saying is god
i'm not happy i'm not grateful i'm not
content of where you put me and i need
to be like somebody else listen if god
wanted you to be like someone else he
would have made you like somebody else
but he didn't he created you with a
design and with the plan for to be
exactly who you are and to make the most
out of what he has given you you are
created in love by love and for love and
he has a great plan and purpose for your
life you have a mission and a mission is
possible but before you can answer that
mission you have to know there is a
mission you have to know that i'm here
on purpose and when you know that you're
here on purpose i don't have to spend my
whole life wishing i was somebody else
because the god of this universe who was
sovereign in control of all of it
in his design and in his wisdom and in
his love for us he made me who i am
for a reason and he didn't make a
mistake and he didn't make a mistake on
you okay so for someone out there that's
listening
and they're like this is great tim
absolutely gosh i want that i'm longing
for that everything you're saying but
yes like how does someone start when
someone does feel like that they're in
the cycle of comparison or the cycle so
good hopelessness yes what's the thing
to be like okay how do i connect to my
god-given design how do i connect to my
such a good question and it's one of the
things that we really try to focus on
here is we talk about the principles
kind of from a very you know 30 000 foot
view but then we also want to get into
the practical of the every single day
and a lot of people come and say timmy
how do i know what my mission what my
calling my purpose is and i'll first say
i don't know exactly but have your eyes
ever been opened to a knee to a hurting
person to um a church that's doing
something too cool to a non-profit that
you feel really strongly towards and
have your has your heart ever felt
compassion to want to step up and do
something for that hurting person or
that person in the hospital or that
person in the old folks home or a person
on the side of the street if so that's
probably god saying hey i want you to go
meet that need and when you step out
with that little bit of courage with
that little bit of faithfulness with
that little bit of of boldness and you
do that a lot of times you don't know
the the end road the end the the
destination but when you say yes i feel
like god shows you as you continue to
grow and you for me is when i was 15
years old and i was in the jungles of
the philippines and i met a boy who was
born with his feet on backwards and
because of that he was viewed as cursed
as insignificant as less than and he was
a throwaway but god was like he's not a
throwaway to me and he better not be a
throwaway to you and because of that you
know i knew that was my calling and
we've i you know and i know till my my
last breath that that's gonna be my
calling is fighting for every single boy
or girl around the world like him yeah
and being obedient in the small things
that's right and the small things that's
good
tim tebow's our guest sorry
it's all good it's all good we'll just
let you loose man let you run it's good
mission possible is the book go create a
life that counts it came on sale this
week you can pick it up anywhere great
books are sold we'll be back with a
little more from the man himself tim
tebow
[Music]
if you're looking for ways to update
your home without blowing the budget
i've got it for years i've been telling
you about our friends at blinds.com
blinds.com makes it simple to shop top
quality blinds shades and interior
shutters from home with easy online
ordering and free
shipping with blinds.com there's no need
to renovate your entire home just change
out what's on your windows with upscale
choices like faux wood blinds cellular
and roller shades or even outdoor shades
plus blinds.com guarantees the perfect
fit whether you do it yourself or you
have them measure and install everything
for you shop their latest looks and see
how much you can save at blinds.com
today the easy and affordable way to
make your home more beautiful is
blinds.com
[Music]
rachel cruz ramsey personality number
one best-selling author is my co-host
today another number one best-selling
author and another number one book out
tim tebow is with us the new book is
mission
possible go create a life that counts uh
we'll know next week if it's a number
one technically but i am pronouncing it
now as a number one i'm i'm speaking
too kind of pathetically or
prophetically existence
i'm with it here so mission possible go
create a life that counts
there is this strange dance we have
that mixes into this message um
and around here we always quote saint
ambrose uh
pray like it all depends on god work
like it all depends on you that's right
and so sometimes i meet people of faith
who uh need to get off their tail yes
and go do something yes and sometimes i
meet people of faith who are a little
bit too dependent on their own power and
they missed out on they missed out on
exponential yes because they didn't do
both yeah you've got to do the planting
it was so that you're going to reap what
you sow you've got to do the work you've
got to do
no discipline seems pleasant at the time
but it yields a harvest of righteousness
you've got to do those things and then
god comes along and joins if you keep
your arms open right i was literally
listening to a sermon on sunday and he
he brought up both of those and then he
said
do both
do both right we need to have faith that
that god is is sovereign and god is in
control and we need to have faith
knowing that that you know we got to do
what we're called to do but he's going
to do what he wants to do and he's in
control of all of it but we also are
called co-laborers for a reason
co-workers and also we know that he's
given us
a mission a job a responsibility
but are we truly going after it
like it depends on us
and honestly that's one of the reasons
why my dad is my biggest hero because
his entire adult life he has truly gone
after and i got to see all these other
people in the church and they would talk
about it and they would raise their hand
it was all this cool stuff but i was
like
but you don't do anything
it's it's really cool but man i just i
wanted to be like my dad because he was
all about it
he was all about it his whole entire
adult life i saw him loving people that
could literally not do anything for him
yeah you see i didn't want to be that
person that
i would i would talk about god's love
for humanity but you know what when when
we look at scripture and we look at
god's love which is agape the four types
of love in the greek and in agape being
most admirable you know in the best
definition i've ever heard of it was to
choose the best interest for another
person and act on their behalf but you
know what's in the bible more than agape
is agapao
because agape is the noun agapao is the
verb
it's in the bible more
than agape why because it's one thing to
know about god's love it's a whole
nother thing to go out there and show
god's love to choose the best interest
for humanity and act on their behalf and
you know what i think there's going to
be a lot of people one day that they're
gonna know that right now they know
about god's love but man they didn't
choose to go act because i think the
most selfish thing that you can do is
once you you have been rescued
is you know about what god sent his son
jesus to do and you believe that it what
he did on the cross and you believe he
accounted for you and my pastor always
says once you've been rescued you're on
the rescue team yeah go be on the rescue
team go bring that that mission go bring
that message go bring that opportunity
to every single person around the world
because the most selfish thing you can
do is once you know that to hold on to
it to not bring and show that love to
the world and i don't want to be someone
that that that that knowledge stops with
me i want i want to be a i want to be a
verb listen i was home school but i know
the difference between a noun and a verb
all right listen i i want i want to show
it might be why you know that yeah oh
you went to tennessee we can explain it
a little bit okay
but honestly you know
i believe every day we share the gospel
but every now and then we use words
and when those two match now i think you
have great impact you need to keep in
mind florida's a really good school it
is and i went to tennessee and there's a
lot of people that went to florida that
work for me
let's talk about the glory days and you
can talk about the early 90s okay
you know it's cool that is true i
remember when the celebrator had to look
back 30 years
they just keep coming so no it's awesome
let's go back and celebrate peyton and t
martin that's cool you know
96 and seven were awesome years huh
it's a jersey that's that's 35 years old
you're like that's set yeah it's okay
it's true it's being a ball fan we're
dedicated
i was i was talking about the academics
i know well you can turn football
academy
i love it honestly i want tennessee to
be good i genuinely do
i'm i'm i'm being i'm sorry i'm honestly
you're just being serious with god
because i love the sec but two we
freaking need them to be good again like
come on and they're getting back at
least this year they were exciting with
their hello gunslinger yeah
one of the greatest questions you can
ask is does my life change other
people's lives for the better that's one
of the statements towards the end of the
book and uh one of my best friends
pastor that's graduated he's gone on to
be with the lord you should say if it's
not helpful
if it doesn't promote healing and it
doesn't spread hope why are you doing it
yeah and so you get to the end and go
you know did i leave an impact did i
leave a mark that's right and that's how
you know if you were on mission that's
right
and you know i believe that uh one of
the greatest forms of tragedy is to be
successful in all the things that don't
matter
and i think there's going to be a lot of
people one day that are going to look
back and they're going to say you know
what i was successful in all of these
things but none of them matter and man i
just don't want to say that or feel that
or know that about my life is you know
i've been fortunate in a few areas to be
a little bit successful
man but
success is
doesn't matter but i do think that every
single person that has been blessed to
have a little bit of success i believe
that we can turn that into significance
because i believe success is about us
but significance is about other people
and i encourage all those people that
are listening right now and you've been
blessed with with success you have the
chance to turn that into significance by
looking outward by looking at people
that need you that need that help and
you can make a difference in their life
because what are you going to think one
day oh my gosh what are you gonna brag
about in your deathbed look at all the
success i had i've been fortunate to
talk to a lot of people on their
deathbed whether that's been in
hospitals it's been in death row it's
been in so many different places and so
many different countries and very rarely
do you ever hear someone talk about an
accomplishment yep but you do hear them
talk about meaning
and purpose or you hear them say
i wish i would have done more
meaning purpose significance things that
actually really mattered
yep that's exactly right yeah you don't
uh get to the end of the
end of the thing and somebody worried
about what car they're driving it
doesn't it doesn't come up no but he was
the most stories when he dies is dead
that's right but but i will say this
i'll tell you honestly so many times in
my life i i i will say that i have
gotten caught up in that
i think man i i've so many times i've
gotten caught up i thought man but if we
can win this championship man but if we
can beat tennessee again man but but but
if we can win the sec man but if we can
win this championship man but but if we
can if i can prove the doubters wrong
and be a first round draft pick if we
can prove them wrong and get to the
playoffs you know and those aren't bad
things but too many times in my life
they were everything yeah and and god
had to say no no no that's not
everything that's a game
and it's okay i know you love it that's
a good thing i put you here for that but
but remember i didn't put you here for a
game
you know i remember i was uh i just won
the the heisman trophy and then a few
weeks later i was in thailand i got a
chance to do some cool things and i saw
a boy that was starving on the side of
of this feeding center that was
squatting in this corner of a ditch and
he was wearing an orange and blue number
15 tim tebow jersey and i just started
weeping because i knew god was pricking
my heart saying you think that you're
cool or you think that you matter
because you just won this trophy and
people are celebrating you
who's celebrating that boy you see i
died just as much for that boy as i died
for you
and you know what a game's not going to
do anything for that boy but you can
so don't remember why you don't forget
why you're here don't forget why i died
i didn't die for a game i died for
humanity i died for that boy
i want you to love that boy man
yeah and that's so much too of like
even here on this show when we just talk
about money right like that's like the
big
arc of it and it's like you know getting
people in this place to be free and to
have the margin the ability to go and
give right now that we're mad at stuff
right whether it's winning a football
game or driving a nice whatever like all
that's not bad it's not bad but it's but
it's the thing that you're attaching
your hope and your joy to that's exactly
right so i think that's i think that's
awesome the new book is mission possible
go create a life that counts with our
friend tim tebow thanks for coming by my
brother thank you guys
thank you i'm so grateful for y'all you
too brother this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
look i love real estate and i want you
to have a house but i don't want a house
to have
you
that's why you need to get in touch with
churchill mortgage to make sure you do
this right these guys are awesome
they'll help you get on a smarter
mortgage plan because they're committed
to doing what's right for
you
that means they check in every year with
free consultations to help you stay on
the right plan they show you how to save
money and interest so you can build
wealth faster they walk you through the
total cost of your loan so you can make
the best choice
basically they care that's why we call
them ramsey trusted you can achieve
debt-free home ownership and churchill
is here to help go to their site
churchillmortgage.com
ramsey to start your approval or get
more information
[Music]
[Applause]
rachel cruz ramsey personality is my
co-host today in the lobby of ramsey
solutions on the debt free stage chaz
and karina are with us hey guys how are
you hey dave here good to have you guys
where do you live uh cincinnati ohio
welcome to nashville and all the way
here to do a debt-free scream how much
have you paid off 120.
how long did this take uh four years and
five months good deal
a good deal and your range of income
during that time 45 to 70. wow
good for you what do you guys do for a
living
i work for a payroll company in
cincinnati and i'm on like a leadership
team there okay i started out on like uh
the entry level and worked my way up for
the five years awesome good for you good
for you when i stay home with the kids
and all right do what i can on the side
so this way there's three of them what
are their ages you got your hands full
we've got four and a half two and a half
and six months oh you got a full-time
job
no question
yeah you're busier than all of us 120
000 is what kind of debt
student loans
he points at himself just me
my student my stupid mistake
okay
so what happened uh four years ago they
got you guys on this journey this ramsay
journey yeah well um four and a half
four years ago we had zeke
and um we kind of started the journey
when we got married we did fpu when we
were engaged
and knew that he had a lot of
student loans that we wanted to work
through and
our minimum payments were so big and our
income was not very big and it just i
don't know we just could not get
traction it just took a lot and then uh
the summer that we had him we taught an
fpu class
we're telling up the numbers and we were
like what are we doing like how is it
still this big
um
and so we had been renting a house and
we moved back into an apartment and we
just started making changes and i
started door dashing and doing other
things and
um
yeah we just we're like we got to do
this like yeah
we have to address this it's not going
to go away if we don't hit it right yeah
you guys did it and had multiple kids
during the time too which is a feat i'm
like i'm so impressed yeah i am that's a
lot it is a lot yeah you guys are you
guys have done a lot in four and a half
years yeah yeah big deal a lot of a lot
of growing in your career and going up
the ladder and a lot of babies coming on
and all this other stuff so
uh what do you tell people now the key
to getting out of debt is you did it
yeah um well for us one of the big
things was using every dollar we had
been just using a spreadsheet that chas
had created that was
good but every dollar is different and
it worked easier it was easier for me to
look at it and say oh this is how much
we have to throw at the loans
so that was a big part and then god's
faithfulness obviously um really big
deal and then
just remembering that as we go along and
as we would get discouraged looking back
at ways that god had provided things
that people had given us things that we
were able to find for next to nothing or
free um it was amazing um
yeah that was a really really big thing
that's so interesting that you say that
because i do find when people kind of
draw the line in the sand and say we're
not going to debt and in fact we're
going to work our way out of it it
forces you to think differently and get
creative in life right so as a parent
because a lot of people listening have
little ones at home
like what did you guys do as a family
to find things of like okay we don't
have a ton of money to spend because
we're throwing everything at the debt so
how did you survive four
years of
sacrifice what all did you do yeah well
we had a small business that we ran we
started it um before zeke was born and
then we just closed it down this last
year we had a donut pop-up shop that we
did on the weekends and it was a lot of
fun and it was very creatively
fulfilling for me um and then we just
realized this year we're like we just
can't take it the direction we want to
right now without
uh going into that for it yeah but then
like my family lives nearby so we were
able to you know do sunday dinners with
them and i cook a lot
um we have a good group of friends and
we were able to spend time with them
which makes it easier than
like i don't know they're not like oh
let's all go to dinner because they were
very understanding too yeah like it was
the the joke was always like is that in
the budget yeah you know
yeah yeah that's that's cool
well what amounts to is you kind of just
did what people used to do
yeah like have relationships right cook
and stuff yeah yeah instead of trying to
buy your way through something yeah that
that's you you that's fabulous very very
well done very proud of y'all thank you
great job who was your biggest
cheerleader outside the two of you
um i mean both our parents were i mean
um we were
blessed with other other people that we
didn't even really know we were um a
cheerleader gave us 500 like gift card
oh wow go somewhere with the handwritten
note that
no idea where it came from but someone
heard our story or knew what we were
going through and wanted to provide
things like that
someone also helped bless us with a
minivan that we drove down here too wow
yeah uh so we've had some people who
have really wanna wanted to see us kind
of thrive um and you know get behind us
but uh our friends uh and our our
families
big big cheerleaders so what would be
the hardest thing you would say to
someone
that's about to enter into this journey
what was the toughest thing you did in
that four years
getting started i think um
our shovel just wasn't very big yeah it
felt like we couldn't
do it um yeah we like because we took
you know we did it um the classes we
talked about it we kind of had some
budget meetings here and there right we
tried to keep going but like it was
always just
very hard to kind of like our you know
we're here with our our garden shovel
here right like
and it just seemed like we were never
gonna get anywhere um and then as you
know my job i was blessed at my job with
you know getting more raises and stuff
and
we started to see that oh we we can do
this or we the extra side jobs and stuff
so like yeah just getting started was
actually really hard yeah
well and until you start chipping away
at it it's hard to believe it's actually
going to go away yes yeah just standing
there looking at it it's overwhelming
yeah very but when you start the climb
you go well okay maybe and then maybe
and then maybe you know
you know you just you get that process
so very well done you guys very very
well done we've got a copy of baby steps
millionaires for you number one
bestseller that's the next chapter in
your story for sure and another copy of
total money makeover for you to give
away to someone to inspire them you guys
have inspired a lot of people today just
by showing up and doing your debt free
scream all right let's get the kiddos
into the shot and introduce them their
names and ages we want this to be a
family affair because it has been all
along this is what happened while they
were getting out of debt
that's fine
oh
yeah so this is zeke he's four and a
half we have inez she's two and a half
and then this is eliza she's
a little over six months all right very
fun beautiful family you guys have
changed your family tree very well done
we're proud of you you're heroes great
great work all right chaz and karina
zeke anez and eliza from cincinnati ohio
120 000 paid off in four years and five
months making 45 up to 70. count it down
let's hear a debt-free scream
three two one
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
that is how it's done right there
oh man
absolutely fabulous
absolutely fabulous precious family yeah
so a lot of times we hear well people i
don't make 200 000 a year well they
don't they made 45.
and they started and during the time
they go to 70 and single income she's
full-time stay-at-home mom they do the
side hustle with the donuts the pop-up
donuts and uh they look good the
pictures of them look good i kind of
want one right now but um but the uh uh
man i mean it's uh uh
that's those numbers are
this is very
this is a long journey and there's
nothing flashy it's little tick tick
tick tick tick and then the wall falls
yep it's that diligence you know that
we're talking about earlier i'm like man
being faithful and being diligent and
the small day-to-day stuff is what moves
the needle right and especially with
this situation you're like that's it
that's what they did
hardest part was getting started because
you're overwhelmed
and again like she said she's like yeah
we're looking at our shovel and it's a
garden shovel compared to the student
loan and the student loans i think
sometimes are the hardest because at
least a car alone you're like can we
sell it can we there's a tangible i
don't know but but sallie mae it's like
it's just 120 and everyone has it and
all you don't even like you can justify
yourself out of that and so the fact
when people buckle down and they do it
on just that i'm like it's impressive
and they are they're incredible and now
they're free
now they're free completely free they're
free
they're free did i mention they're free
this is good stuff i love it
very well done this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
rachel cruz ramsey personality is my
co-host today we will be in dallas on
october the 22nd for the smart
conference it's our biggest event of the
year
all of the ramsey personalities plus uh
craig and amy groschel will be speaking
on marriage it's going to be a huge deal
rachel the tickets are selling so fast
that um
if you don't i know it's october 22nd
but they're going to sell out this
thing's this the smart conference
exploded it's going crazy i think people
were kind of waiting for us to get back
out there i mean you know they're ready
i think they're ready to do anything
they're ready to go do stuff yeah and
the wealth building tickets are selling
uh building wealth tickets are selling
too it's rachel uh george and i will be
doing an event called building wealth
and uh it'll be in orlando on may the
19th it just went on sale and it's
selling like crazy thank you guys we
appreciate your response uh but for the
rest of you that have not yet got your
tickets for the smart conference or the
building wealth uh conference in orlando
uh you do need to go and get them the
tickets aren't that much and go to
slash events ramseysolutions.com them up
immediately because
um it appears there's a there's like a i
don't know a pent-up demand or whatever
you call me a lot of people a lot of
people want to do something and we want
people yes yes yes yes and they're fun
we love our events so we're excited to
be back out as well to be with you guys
to get out and hang out with people
again it's just going to be building
wealth we're going to do book signings
there and everything so yeah absolutely
and deloney and uh coleman ken coleman
are coming and we're going to build them
into the event as well and they'll be
doing book signings so every one of us
will be signing books every one of us
will be doing stuff we're we're looking
forward the the building wealth events
are small they're only about 2 000
people and so that's why they're going
to sell out really really quickly i
think that one's already almost like
half sold out in like four days yeah
it's just it went fast so if you want to
come or orlando we're going to be
announcing uh five other cities soon on
the building wealth uh one more in the
spring and four in the fall and we'll
let you know those as soon as we can get
the venues under contract and let you
guys know where we're coming and when
but that's going to end up being a tour
is what it amounts to because we're just
all the ramsay personalities are like
we've got to get back out there
it's crazy so we're excited to be out
there teaching again we love a live
stream but also we like being with
people more yeah
i i don't love the live stream but uh
but i i it's i mean it's easy to do but
uh it's a lot less trouble than doing a
venue and put taking a
load of stuff across the country and all
that kind of stuff but uh but there's
just something about being with human
beings
that's a big deal hannah is with us
hannah's in maryland hi hannah welcome
to the ramsey show
hi thank you so much for taking a call
sure what's up
um so i kind of have a two-part question
um as was about three weeks ago we
finished baby step number two
congrats
thank you so much it's been it was a
journey
um but so we are we started our 15
towards retirement for baby step four
and now we are looking at conversations
for our kids and i'm just running in
circles um
we have four kids they range from ten
years to nine months
and
my amazing in-laws started 529 plans for
all of them
um when they were babies
and so we don't know
should we
um
where should we start saving money for
them since they do all already have 529s
that have been started and
should we contribute equally to all four
of them or start with the oldest one and
work our way down yeah it's a great
question hannah actually my husband and
i in january we we sat down with our
smart vester pro and looked at
everything including the 529s for the
kids um i realized we didn't open one
for little charles so we were like
and so we were looking though to see
how to
you know what it looks like and run the
numbers so i would say first and
foremost hannah i would sit down with
the smart investor pro because they're
going to be able to tell you hey here's
what the market's doing here's what it
looks like they factor in inflation and
tuition and all of that and you're going
to be able to see the growth that your
money's going to have and yeah depending
on the age of the kid it's going to be
depend on the amount of money you're
going to need and all of it so there's
multiple
options here but sitting down to run the
numbers is what's key and having
somebody in your corner to help do that
for me just gave me a piece of mind yeah
but i it is not
fair is not equal
and so if you've got an older child it's
gonna you're gonna need to put more in
for the older child than you put for the
younger child because the younger
child's got more time for the money to
grow
and so um the point is that we're gonna
take care of each of them school um and
it takes a different amount of money to
take care of each of them different
schools so
that that's perfectly fine and yeah and
they can help you run the calculations
with a smartvestor pro seth is in boise
idaho hi seth how are you
great dave how are you than i'm honored
to speak with you you too i'd love to
hear it
hey um so i've got a quick question um
my wife and i are trudging through baby
step two
um
we've been we have about 27k in debt and
we're about 20 months
left on our plan
um and i'm working about 80 hours a week
with my full-time job i work remote
doing software and then drive uber in
the evenings um
and so i'm i'm hustling really hard
what's your housing income
uh so my my
retirement full-time job i make about
105 a year
before taxes um and then with my uber i
can make last year i made about twenty
thousand um well that was before
expenses after expenses it was like
seven
um so
and that and that was only driving about
half the year so
this year driving all the year i i'd say
you're all probably about doubling that
you're making 125 000 why is it taking
you a year to pay off 27 000
well i guess that's just
with the plan the way we've got it set
up we're we're putting 1500
a month to our debt plan why um
uh well where's your money
well the money we have six kids we have
kids in college we've got you know we've
got yeah there's just a bunch of okay
that's the house
everything yeah so there's there's a
bunch of different stuff going on we've
got
so yeah okay so
i'm sorry i'm just just trying to get
clear so what's your question how can we
help you well my my question is so my
wife came to me today and and
she's just getting really frustrated um
and she told me she feels like you know
she's fearful that i'll continue the
grind
even after we're debt-free
and i'm wondering
well i don't know i don't know if it's
just
the
we've been doing it for so long and you
know we've just now i've gotten my
income up over the last two years uh
before it was down in the 75 000 that
kind of thing and
um it's just in the last couple
about year that we've really
said hey we can do this we can you know
really make some extra money and and
throw it towards you but what have you
said or done that made her think you
want to do this like 80-hour week as a
as a way of life
um
i don't know maybe it's maybe it's the
way i
um like cause she'll sometimes say well
i'd really like you to come home
you know it's
10 o'clock at night i'm still out
driving and
uh and
and i'm going well i'm not at my goal
yet i gotta hit my goal for the day kind
of thing so she did so
connected from you seth i would think as
a wife i think in this process one of
the things is that you do
there's so many hours in the day and if
you're applying you know all those hours
to working and getting out of debt which
is awesome it's the gazelle intensity
but the relational factor if there's not
the connection and she doesn't feel a
level of somewhat safety even and like
hey yeah we feel connected in this this
is the grind but we're on this team
together versus a him versus her and
you're missing each other all the time
and you go in marriage like that for a
long time that takes a toll on your
marriage and so there's a level that i
would have and say hey let's have
boundaries around this and there's a
certain time maybe at night so many
nights a week that i'm home at this time
and when we're together
that you guys are spending quality time
together too as a married couple because
in this process it should actually what
we find
help your marriage and even though
there's a lot of sacrifice involved
versus tearing you guys apart i'm
hearing it being torn apart and i i just
kind of have some red flags going up
yeah i think you need to um make sure
we're both on goal
and we identify what the goal is and
what happens when we hit the goal
meaning that we're going to knock this
debt out and then i'm immediately going
to not do uber anymore and i'm
immediately going to back down to x
number of hours
as soon as we're dead free
and you got to lay that out i also think
that the two of you are not doing your
budget together
because there's still a lot of money
missing you got six kids and a couple in
college okay
that's that explains a lot of where some
of your money's going but still 1500 a
month out of 120 000 that's only 18 000
a year i'm gonna want to dial that in
and maybe that's her part of this she
helps dial the home place in to get you
off the road even faster but you've just
got to make the
time to
stay connected as rachel's saying
good question brother keep at it you're
going to get it just make sure you stick
with her this is the ramsay show
hey it's rachel cruz co-host on the
ramsay show if you want to do your
debt-free scream live on the show visit
ramseysolutions.com
debt free screen we'd love for you to
come to nashville and tell dave your
story that's ramseysolutions.com
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career
you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions it's the ramsey show where
debt is dumb cash is king and the paid
off home mortgage has taken the place of
the bmw as the status symbol of choice
i'm dave ramsey your host thank you for
joining us america rachel cruz's ramsey
personality is my co-host today along
with christina ellis ramsey personality
so we've got ramsey personalities
everywhere in here i'm outnumbered by
the ladies right now
it's a ladies segment but it's not it is
women's month or something right it was
international women's day yesterday
yesterday okay
something like that it's like women's
month well it's just it's i'm sure it
was something i saw
or was it monday i think it was monday
i'm behind too
i don't know i've obviously always lived
my life that every day was absolutely
right preach it and then i know i'm good
okay that's right i know i'm covered
that way so christina ellis ramsey
personality is new on board in the last
year and uh we've been introducing her
to you guys she has a number one or a
best it was a number one best-selling
book right
best-selling book a best-selling book
okay
i couldn't know if it was number one or
not where she'll she went and uh
maybe maybe we'll push it back up there
but anyway the uh she went and at her
mom's suggestion gathered up 500
thousand dollars in scholarships and
went and not only got her undergrad but
got her master's degree for vanderbilt
and uh all completely free and so we
thought she'd have something to say
about the student loan crisis and
brought her on to be part of the team
and talk about this and student loans
are popping out there right now the um
the payments uh everybody they keep
kicking the can down the road but now
it's may 1
they're going to start back and word is
i just saw a survey that said 93 of the
students are not our former students are
not ready to start their student loan
payments back yeah
we've seen some crazy stats out there
there's so much anxiety around this
topic right now and i've actually heard
there's a study by ramsey here that six
and ten people have not been making any
payments at all so this has been such a
great opportunity for people to make
payments and get ahead but a lot of
people have just for whatever reason not
been making payments so this pressure
and this weight is coming down on them
right now that another study said that
27 people don't even 27 of people don't
even think they can pay it at all that
they can ever do it again which is just
crazy yeah well it's crazy too because
i'm like you can get in this habit and
people have obviously of just not paying
right
versus hearing the people that are
putting money towards their student loan
and putting their getting their
principal way down in the moment right
where you're not having to pay but they
are
and catching up so whether may first
comes true or even if they kick the can
down further still
attacking your student loan during time
it's the smartest thing to do
absolutely
yeah it's definitely a time to attack it
and i think it's great we've seen a lot
of people who have taken advantage of it
and that's just awesome because you're
seeing people who've paid off their
balances or they're making significant
progress but if you're in that group of
people who haven't been paying
let this be your wake-up call this is
still time you know there's still time
where the interest isn't accruing where
it's not adding up so take advantage of
the time you do have and if they do kick
the can down the road even further then
you'll get more time to make payments
without interest i would not count on
that though what you need to count on is
what you can control and that's you
and get your butt in gear and start
attacking this thing
it's time to get real serious about your
budget it's time to get real serious
about what you need to sell it's time to
get real serious about an extra job it's
time to get real serious about not
eating out and get your stinkin student
loans knocked out man sally mae is an
ugly woman and she will not leave until
she's evicted
i mean you have to kick her to the
street and and she she you know she's
not going to leave she's not going to
voluntarily move out you're going to
have to kick her out i think it's part
of the problem too though is i feel like
i hear people that will say yeah i'm not
paying on my student loans because
they're going to be the government's
going to forgive them you know like
there's still this mindset
that it's just going to it's going to
disappear and go away and i'm like man
like sitting on that
defense right versus the offense and be
like no i'm gonna be proactive and
actually do something about this versus
waiting so it's it's wild but you see it
all the time i feel like you're you're
like in this so much right and that's
why one of the things i want to talk
about today are some of the strategies
that people are going to hear about
that's really bad advice things that
people should avoid so one of the things
that's going to be a temptation for many
people is for parents it's the chance to
pause your payments or lower the
payments and it sounds really great at
first you know i don't have to deal with
it right now that 27 of people who you
know they don't think that they can pay
their loans they might think you know
what let's do forbearance but that's
just again kicking the can down the road
but this time your interest it will be
accruing so when you get to the end of
that time
it's going to be an even higher
bad news yeah and the other one that any
time you do something that
feels good now
it's going to be bad later
forbearances one the income repayment
plan where you take the lowest possible
payment because you have a low income
and what that means is you're not paying
it
enough
and it's building up on you it's going
to catch up on you right right i was on
a ramsey plus coaching call a group
coaching call the other day and there
was the saddest story there was a 70
year old woman on the call and she took
out her loans in 1999
took out 80 000 in student loans she had
a series of unfortunate events happen
her husband passed away she got hit by a
tornado her house did her house burn
down all these different things but she
signed up for an income based repayment
program and now her student loans are
144
000
she's paid 79 000 towards those loans
but because the the the interest just
have kept accruing it just didn't even
change over the interest it's gone
backwards okay that's so interesting i
just saw an article today we were in a
content meeting talking about an episode
of doing this kind of stuff on the radio
crew show and and there was an article
that came out and it was like i took out
30 000 and now it's over 93 000. how is
this happening
and
and that's what's so that's what makes
me so angry about the whole process too
is i'm like at 18 no one's explaining to
these students
hey this is what interest is
this is what happens when it grows
because it can feel defeating of like
i'm paying on my principal but because
the interest is stacking up against me
and i can't get ahead you know it's this
it feels so overwhelming so overwhelming
and lastly we don't need to worry about
it because the government's going to
forgive it
right it's not a concern
they're going to come save us
how do you feel about that dave yeah
anytime someone says i'm from the
government and i'm here to help that's
the scariest words in the english
language not ronald reagan oh yes it was
i know my quotes
what's crazy with student loans i
actually saw a statistic the other day
that you know high school students
they're 18 year old year olds they have
this financial aid package come in and
at the bottom of this package is a total
number in this financial aid package it
has grants and scholarships but they
also lace student loans in there and the
statistics said you know a huge
percentage percentage of students they
don't even realize that that money is
not free yes they don't realize that
they're signing for a student loan they
think that what they have in that
package is just
money that some adult gave to them that
they're not going to be responsible for
which is absolutely crazy we have to do
better and that's what i'm so excited
with the borrowed future what we've done
with that because it highlights that
toxic industry it highlights these
people out here who are taking advantage
of students
absolutely the borrowed future
documentary you can see it at google
play you can see it on apple tv you can
see it on amazon prime
hundreds of thousands have viewed it if
you have a college student uh and coming
up anywhere near in your future you
should show it to them you should watch
it and the rest of you ought to watch it
anyway just so you get pissed off and
tell congress to quit doing this because
they're messing over the american public
with the student loan program christina
ellis ramsey personality thanks for
hanging out with us thanks for having me
this is the ramsay show
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
um
[Music]
still on baby step number one huh
how'd you guess
with health care costs rising learn how
christian healthcare ministries can help
you make the most out of your budget
visit
chministries.org budget don't worry it's
worth it
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
rachel cruz ramsey personality is my
co-host today
open phones at
825-5225
half of all americans over 65 will need
long-term care and the average cost of
that care is 138 000 you've got to plan
your long-term care needs right now
i talk to people all the time whose plan
is to let medicaid pay for it i got news
for you medicaid won't pay for
everything and medicaid isn't is welfare
it's based on the fact that you're poor
is the only way you get
government-funded nursing homes
that's why we recommend long-term care
insurance for someone who's aged 60 and
over
it helps pay for the nursing home care
assisted living in-home care costs like
medical equipment getting dressed eating
home modification so you can get around
safely in your home does all of that
long-term care insurance protects your
family too
your spouse your kids won't have to bear
the financial or emotional burden of
taking care of you
our endorsed local provider network will
help you understand your long-term care
insurance options and find the right
policy for you
find an elp for long-term care have them
sit down and start talking to you if
you're 60 or if your parents are
and you need to make sure nursing home
is taken care of ramsay solutions dot
com slash
long term
care be sure you check it out sterling
is in raleigh north carolina hi sterling
welcome to the ramsey show
hey thank you for taking my call sure
what's up
hey so i am 17. um i have a one thousand
dollar car uh i have five thousand
dollars in a roth ira and i'm putting
500 in a month right now
um i make about 1500 a month and i'm
still doing full-time high school
i've got free college and i've been
through financial peace university and
i'm trying to figure out what i need to
do with my money and if i need to open
an index fund or how i should be setting
aside money for a house
i think you should run for president
oh my gosh young man you're on you're on
fire what are you doing to make all this
money
uh so i started out as a painter when i
was 15. my dad helped me get the job and
then right now i'm working as a hvac
cleaner so i help a guy clean air ducts
and
dryer vents yeah nice my husband did
that through college sterling yeah
yeah yeah that's hard work it's nasty
work too but you're not afraid of hard
work get get her done man i'm proud of
you very well done so uh you're heading
off to school is that is that the plan
what's the plan when you graduate
yes sir so i'm a junior right now i'm
planning on dual enrolling some this
next year um and hopefully i'll get some
college hours in and then once i
graduate high school i'm planning on uh
hopefully i'm thinking about majoring in
business and then maybe going to trade
school at some point after that um
that's my plan so far i think you got a
great plan very cool
very cool so your question is what to do
with all this money
yes sir should i be saving it up for a
house should i be putting this in an
index fund because i'm already maxing
out my roth ira how's college paid for
uh so my dad actually works at a college
right now so i get a free tuition and
he's got like half the books i need okay
all right i would i would not try to get
too fancy i'm just gonna park it as an
insurance policy to make sure
that if something goes sideways on the
free part of the college you can still
finish
um and yes so the worst case scenario is
you have i don't know 30 or 40 or 50 000
when you graduate oh darn
and then you just have to figure out
buying a house at that point but if
you've got that in a good mutual fund
just do something like an index fund i
think that'd be just fine but the big
deal here is
sometimes uh
some of our our plans get derailed and i
i always want it's more important for
you as especially sharp and as much of
an ambition and much of a go-getter as
you are
to complete school and to complete it
debt-free
that is more valuable than any amount of
money you will ever make on a mutual
fund in terms of the actual math
in other words you will be more valuable
by
many times more than this money will
make in a mutual fund so the investment
is my secondary concern my primary
concern is you and making sure that if
if something blew up over there with
your dad or whatever then you can still
finish school and if you and if it
doesn't if the plan goes exactly as you
got it laid out you're still gonna have
a pile of money for you know your first
to get into your first job in your first
house and that kind of thing yeah
because i'd love the
obviously the motivation of investing in
all that sterling you're you're doing it
right the earlier the better but also
kind of with the caveat that between 17
and 22 years old there's a lot of
transition there's a lot of change you
have no clue kind of what life is going
to bring you and so you're not going to
not become wealthy if you start really
kind of hardcore investing at 22 versus
17 if that makes sense so having that
cash available like you're saying dave i
think is so smart because again whether
you go to college and then you're like
okay i want to move to a different state
i'm going to need cash to be able to
move who knows maybe you meet a girl and
you're like i want to propose and you're
going to get a ring like there's just so
much transition that can happen in that
time and so giving yourself the ability
to have margin with cash to be able to
kind of move and go at the pace you want
is worth it and then once you kind of
settle down after college and figure out
where you're going to live your big your
first job and all of that
then go hardcore into the investing
because that's where you're going to be
which is freaking amazing that you're
going to be on baby steps four five and
six i'm not sure who parents who
sterling's dad and mom are but i think
they are they get the award okay
yes but i wanted to ask him too
there is something though that there is
something in certain people that they
just have this drive and i see that in
my kids like you have kind of that you
know you have kids that they just have
this
natural motivation their natural wiring
is they love anybody naturally cleans
air ducts
to go and work though no that works
i don't think his parents are making him
do that is what i'm saying like there's
something in sterling in in and in
people and it's like they just have that
drive so i'm just applauding him he's
doing an amazing thing good i'm not i'm
not i'm not taking anything away from
you and your parents for sure have done
an incredible job teaching you and
showing you so it is um it's all of it
which is
awesome great job sterling actually have
fun too sterling have fun
have fun
you're 17. you're good you're gonna be
good have fun
uh chelsea's with us in uh phoenix hey
chelsea how are you
hi i'm good thanks for taking my call
sure what's up
so um i have about 50 um 6 000 that's
been in my bank account i have no debt i
guess i'm on baby step number six
and i owe about 59 000 still on my house
and i'm just wanting to know if i should
take like a portion of my savings and
put it towards my house or i don't
really know how much i should really
keep for like my emergency fund yeah
it's a great question so
with baby step three where we're at um
is three to six months worth of expenses
and so making sure you have
expensive you know that set aside are
you chelsea kids single kind of where
are you at um yeah i'm married and i
have two kids seven and three okay okay
so yeah you and your husband can decide
do we want to lean more toward the three
month emergency fund or the six month
but having that cash set aside um and
then ask yourself like do you guys is
there a car that needs to be replaced
for any reason uh are you guys doing any
remodeling is there anything in life
that's going on because when you're on
baby steps four five and six
um you know this is the time we always
say you can kind of take your foot off
the accelerator some and so if there is
stuff to do you're able to but also
though chelsea like gosh after that
emergency fund is funded and throwing a
chunk at the house
it's so nice because you guys just have
the mat you have the money you have the
cash there what's your household
income it's about 165 total okay so what
do you think three to six months of
expenses is
i don't know probably
i don't know maybe like 30. okay let's
call it
let's call it 30 and throw 26 at the
house and pay the house off this year
okay
because you make enough to pay the house
you make enough to cash flow the rest of
it you don't owe but you said 50
something right 59
59 yeah so if we throw 26 at it we got
31 left right
yeah 31 out of 165 and 31 out of 165 in
12 months is very doable
yeah
okay then now we're baby step seven when
you do that and now you're in a position
to become everyday millionaires in no
time you'll be rocking it rocking it you
guys have done a great job
and uh so where you are now we move from
baby steps one two and three is intense
gazelle intensity
four five and six is retirement kids
college are paying off the house
that's intentionality
and so that's what rachel's saying if
you need to pull some money to do
something else this is the time you
would do it but if you don't have a need
for a remodel a new couch or a new car
then
throw that 26 at the house and let's get
this house done this year
[Music]
[Music]
if you're not using puretalk for your
wireless you're paying too much puretalk
gives you the same great 5g coverage on
the same 5g network as one of the big
guys for half the cost the average
family saves over 800 a year go to
puretalk.com and choose the affordable
plan that's right for you with their
30-day risk-free guarantee you have
nothing to lose go to puretalk.com and
enter the promo code ramsey to save 50
off your first month
[Music]
rachel cruz ramsey personality is my
co-host today open phones at
825-5225
bill is in cincinnati hi bill how are
you
i'm doing good dave how are you doing
better than i deserve what's up
well i've taken your class back when my
wife and i did it it was 13 weeks and
not the nine like it currently is and i
was talking to the pastors at my church
and last night after wednesday night
service i talked to the main pastor i
said hey what's up with the request for
doing fbu he says oh yeah we talked
about that go ahead and do it
so my one birthday question is right now
when we did this we didn't have this
current inflationary pressure that we're
currently seeing when you have no idea
what gas prices are going to be from day
to day
and everything else like energy and food
and whatnot
and for somebody starting out that's on
the paycheck to paycheck mode like i was
when i started how would you address
that how would you deal with that
question because that's legit
well in a given month for your budget
you're not going to see food jump
that much
over the course of six months you might
and so you know
if you come up short because you
suddenly saw the cost of bread go up or
whatever you've got it next month you'll
adjust
but um and of course any time as you
know someone is doing their budget the
first time they always guess low on food
anyway so we say whatever you think is
on food you should add some to it
because you're wrong and so if and if
you're worried about inflation add some
more to it you know uh so your your
budget for
your grocery budget it is going to be
higher though
16 to 20 percent like when i checked out
not in one month
it is now compared to what it was like
six months that's what i'm saying six
months ago yes but in a given month and
you're starting your budget at the
beginning of the month for 30 days
you're not going to see dramatic move
you'll see some
but not dramatic and if you do see a
song you will see you'll jump it again
the next month but but a month at a time
you're not going to have to now gas on
the other hand might double
i mean we're in a situation where we
could see that and so energy is not
going to double in one month you're not
going to see your electric bill be
substantially different
in in 30 days
now you might in 30 months
but in 30 days you're not and you're
doing a budget 30 days at a time
and so you know really the only one that
could be out of control is car gasoline
and so just whatever you think it's
gonna be give yourself an extra pad and
put some more in there if you think you
think you're gonna spend 100 put 150 in
there and bill i would say i don't know
if you had this experience but for
people that have not really started this
at all and they haven't been budgeting
they
you know they're kind of just living
that paycheck to paycheck lifestyle when
they sit down and actually do a budget
number one we always say it i'm sure you
felt this you're like okay you kind of
feel like you got a raise because you
actually know where your money's going
and it's just going to make them i just
know for me grocery shopping i have felt
it i'm like i went to costco and i was
like oh my gosh my publix bill it it's
just more it's just more it's crazy what
you're checking out at the grocery store
for versus what you were doing six
months ago exactly but you have to be
able to say okay what am i going to
choose where i'm where am i going to
choose to shop what am i buying when i'm
there you have to be even that much more
selective but it is possible to do it
still on a budget
but they just have to be even that much
more intentional versus if they were
doing this two years ago because it is
it's just things are more expensive let
me tell you what the the a bigger enemy
of their budget is than the actual
inflation
it's using the fear or the irrational
response to inflation as an excuse to
not do a budget i can't do one because i
just don't know you know no you don't
know what the gas is going to be you
just can't do it you can't do it and
that irrational fear and that hyperbole
drama reaction is a bigger enemy to the
budget than the actual inflation is
because it's going to cause people it's
going to cause it's going to cause
people to look for an excuse to not do
this
instead it's the other way around it
gives you that much more reason to do
the budget and really the only thing in
a given 30-day period that's going to be
that could move with some drama is car
gasoline and that's not going to happen
for the rest of their lives that may be
for the next 60 days i don't know what i
mean it's been a while for the last two
weeks
but uh uh but
you know but biden turning on and off
the keystone on and off the russians you
know he can't make up his mind what he's
doing and
until he gets his supply-demand stuff
we're gonna see some variation in the
gas prices it's all over the place and
so um
you know
but again
but i think the truth is what are you
spending on car gas and when it goes up
twenty percent
or
yeah close to 50. or 50 okay so you
spend 100 instead it's 150.
this doesn't and you may and you make 70
000 a year this does not make you broke
i know about it no feels the pain i
don't know you feel it and i know it's
real i'm not i'm not diminishing the pat
that it's real but i'm saying it's not
an excuse to not do a plan totally i'm
without what you can't do yes you can't
use it as an excuse to say i'm not gonna
do it you just go okay i'm gonna budget
high because this crap's out of control
and it hurts yeah so bill on a very
tactical level if you were walking
someone through a budget for the first
time looking back their last three
months and adding up what have i spent
on gas what have i spent on groceries uh
on an average of the past three months
and know that naturally you're gonna
actually spend not necessarily on gas
but you'll spend you could spend less at
the grocery because you're actually on a
budget you're on a plan you're not just
going and buying whatever you want you
actually know i have this amount saved
and you could say hey you're gonna know
it's about a 20
increase on food on on groceries about
50 on gas so from the tactical math side
they can do that to kind of start that
first month's budget and then adjust
from there exactly exactly so it is
crazy though but can we talk about it i
am not denying i know i know you're not
but just like man like the world
it's one of those it feels like that
same angst
when you watch the news and everything
like at the beginning of cove right it's
just like this
guy if everything just feels uncertain
and then like i don't know the housing
mark i don't know all of it it's just
kind of a crazy world do you wake up and
you're like
god march of 2022 it's just it's nuts no
you don't i just feel like i mean it's
crazy to look at what's going on i'm not
trying to be dramatic about it but the
geopolitical thing is crazy and the uh
you know all the stuff going on and but
the gasoline
um
you know we had five dollar gas
under obama
you know and
there wasn't anybody flopping in the
street foaming in the mouth then
you know uh and we got five dollar gas
right now or six dollar gas depending on
where you live
i saw in california
and so
and that it's not good i mean i'm not
i'm not i'm not defending it and it
shouldn't be it it is not real inflation
it's it's policy out of washington dc to
screwed it up that that this is a this
is a economic hurt on the public that is
caused by washington by the decisions
they've made there's no question about
it some of the other inflationary things
are not caused by and you can't blame
biden for every ill out there he didn't
cause it he didn't some of this stuff is
caused by supply chain and supply demand
and the up up evil of the economy by
quarantining all of the workers and
determined deciding that some people
whose job wasn't essential in some
people's was
and so you screw up the labor market you
screw up the lumber market you screw up
the steel market you screw up the chip
market and you screw up manufacturing
you screw up the car market it's on its
head nobody i never seen a car market
like this in my life it's bizarre none
of that was caused by washington that
was all caused by the pandemic and that
will all smooth out eventually but it's
because you did nothing and then you did
triple what you used to do and then you
did and no one was producing nothing
yeah while you were doing nothing and
then when you did triple you used up all
the supply and so you got this geez you
swerved the car you turned the clock
over my coffee well you turned the car
so hard you flipped it you know that's
what the economy did when's it going to
be over what's your crystal ball
24 months
two years 24 months but for all the
supplies
for all the supply chain stuff to smooth
out
it's going to take that long 18 to 24
months it's already smoothed out a lot
on on lumber prices are back down
you know as an example
i didn't know my lover
you know so there's you're starting to
see i mean you stuff you know we don't
have any shortage on the shelves you
know there's stuff hitting the shelves
and that kind of stuff so that's all
that's all the pandemic thing that's the
tsunami
after the earthquake at sea yep
and that's what that was but this this
oil thing it's just politics that's just
morons in washington is all that is and
so you want to be mad at somebody about
the gas thing yeah you can point that in
washington rest of it it's not his fault
you can't blame him for that i don't
think
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
rachel cruz ramsey personality is my
co-host today open phones at eight eight
two five five
[Music]
so rachel and i are talking off air
during the break
here's the thing
when a pandemic hits
when six dollar gas hits
when
a loaf of bread goes up
when there's 73 people trying to buy one
house
and they run the price up
when it's weird out there when you walk
through the grocery store and there's
not crap on the shelves
okay
you have a different
physical
reaction to those
things you have a different
emotional and spiritual reaction to
these things
a lot less drama
to these things
when you are the third pig
remember the third pig
he's the one that had a brick house
and when the big bad wolf came
his pulse rate did not change
he looked out the window and said
oh
there's a wolf
when the big bad wolf came to the other
houses he huffed and he puffed and he
blew their freaking house down and their
lives were coming to an end
right
so when you have
an emergency fund
of three to six months of expenses
when you are living on a budget
when you have worked your butt off and
gotten yourself out of debt
and all this crap comes at you
your pulse rate doesn't change
you go dad gum that's awful it's
inconvenient
they don't have cream cheese at publix
you know
it's just a thing right can i be a
fourth pig
the fourth pitch can i be the fourth pig
i don't know what is the fourth pitch
the fourth pig is that the stepchild
i might be the child after this segment
we'll see what happens you might get
thrown
the fourth pig is you do it all right
thank god for parents that teach you
young you do it you're you're living on
a budget since 21 you save up your
emergency
your fund and your 401k you're you're
doing it okay so you got the brick house
but the dad go move but he's real and
when you when that pig goes to the
grocery store it's like
dang it publix it's so it is though so
you so the fourth pig was a drama
student maybe so the fourth pick can
have the brick house but the fourth pick
also feels it
when you fill up your tank and you're
like no
why is it so expensive or costco i check
out and it's feels like
but it doesn't have to have the level of
drama that you're bringing to it i know
but it god sucks
i didn't say it didn't suck and let me
just tell you let me tell you when it
sucks more when you're not the third pig
i've been there i mean it's like when
you're broke everything that can go
wrong well and then they throw some of
this crap on top of it totally
absolutely your life looks like a
country it's that much more biden wrote
i mean it's awful you know i mean it's
horrible it it it creates it creates a
huge it but the level of stress that you
have the level of anxiety that you have
around inflationary matters changes
dramatically or should totally if you
have your crap together because you've
been following this stuff this is the
stuff that we the stuff that we teach is
the only
principles in finance that work in
prosperous times
and in hard times yes but also so i
would say the fourth pig lives too like
when coveted hit right everything every
i know on the first page i don't make it
up as we go i know i can tell but it's
the same feeling as with covid that the
people that were debt-free had an
emergency fund all of that their level
of fear was way less yeah so they went
through all that but there was still a
level of
like
yeah that part of the level yeah i mean
i get it done but that's what i was just
trying to acknowledge that even though
financially the dollars and cents you
can still pay for the gas and like
adjust your budget and you're fine you
can pay for it yeah the dupes cut the
stupid pump off at 125
i can't fill up the truck
you know
i got to do it twice to fill it up
that's why you need to go green i know
but plug up oh good and you don't have
to do it oh good lord
oh this is going downhill fast but um
so i can't fill up my truck the point is
though
that
when you
are prepared and you have done the
things that we teach
this stuff does not have as much of an
effect on you unless you choose drama
but the drama and the anxiety when
you're broke is
very real yes
i remember i remember that yeah
it's uh you know like deloney says your
body remembers it
you know and and so yeah i i
uh
when the difference in uh four dollar
gas and six dollar gas is
is a huge percentage of your world
because you haven't done these things
yet
um or you've never chosen to do these
things these things being getting out of
debt saving money living on a budget
living on less than you make so that you
can build wealth so that you've got some
buffer between you and all this crap
that's out there
that's the third pick
and it is a real thing that um
you know it doesn't mean you're you're
looking down on the little people it
doesn't mean that at all it just means
that you're the third pig and the the
wolf is out there and he's huffing and
puffing but you're not going to die you
know and so the anxiety if you're if you
have reasonable mental health should be
lower you should not be at the same
drama level
and and so that's a real thing and and
so and that's the one of the benefits
and yeah and it's why you do this yeah
that's right that's right that's why you
do this because guess what if your
anxiety level due to inflationary issues
or whatever it is budgetary problems is
lower it affects your relationship when
you go home at night with your kids and
your spouse you know it affects how you
do your job at work because you're not
sitting and wringing your hands and you
know you can actually concentrate get
your job done guess what and then you
get promotions and so this whole thing
leads to prosperity
and and away from the other
and so this should be yet one more time
in your life if you're out there and
have never decided i'm going to get out
of debt you've never really decided i'm
going to get on a budget i've never
really decided i'm going to build some
wealth and have an emergency fund
this is one more reminder to be the
third pig
because you do have less stress yes you
should have
less stress absolutely
it doesn't mean it's not there it
doesn't mean you don't know it's there
and i was even though doesn't mean
you're in denial that people are having
a hard time somewhere else other than
you you're not a snob that's not what
i'm talking about i'm just saying the
natural reaction should be
it's inconvenient versus
it's world ending yes yes
and even the simple thing i was talking
to someone who's getting out of debt
just being on a budget she was saying
she was like even just that gives me a
sense of control and peace because i
know where to adjust and all of it and
even though it's still tight and it's
like oh it's frustrating
it still gives you this level of control
versus like you're saying just laying
out and being like oh my gosh
everything's just happening to me and i
don't know what to do
giving yourself the ability to control
what you can control and that's this
plan of getting an emergency fund in
place living on a budget working your
way out of debt so you don't owe anyone
anything building up an emergency fund
a fully funded one yeah all of this
right is to get to that point so i
totally concur i just want to say they
were still out of cream cheese so that's
the only thing i was saying in the break
is that
there are still a few things that are
bare on the shelves and
i i'm just saying it's not the end of
the world
and and and it's less the end of the
world it's less drama and less stress
when you're the third pig
or
unless you've graduated to the fourth
pig which is the third pig with drama
apparently but whatever that is i don't
know exactly what that is right now
we're gonna rewrite the fable at this
point but um we have to have a ramsey
version of the fable and rachel's going
to tell us how to do the first time
this is horrible
i don't know
if only you you just you're just scared
of death i'm not going to be empathetic
of the people out there well you know
all you said is that it didn't hurt
month-to-month the grocery bill and i
thought i hurt my every dollar it hurt
when i had to track that dang costco
transaction i thought dad gummit
it's just more it just eats into it my
little line on my over dollar budget
went way further than it did last month
and that means that less pizza for you
and that's a problem
we get the fourth pig when we have less
pizza that's where the fourth pig comes
out pizza pizza depravity
being depraved of pizza deprived
deprivity deprived of pizza however
gravity could be depravity but it could
be just a debris
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
hey it's rachel cruz co-host on the
ramsay show if you want to do your
debt-free stream live on the show visit
ramsaysolutions.com
debt free screen we'd love for you to
come to nashville and tell dave your
story that's ramsey solutions.com
debt free screen
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions it's the ramsey show where
debt is dumb cash is king and the paid
off home mortgage has taken the place of
the bmw as the status symbol of choice
i'm dave ramsey your host rachel cruz
ramsey personality number one
best-selling author is my co-host today
as we answer your questions about your
life and your money
your life your money your relationships
your career your work it's all right
here on the ramsay show brad starts off
this hour in atlanta hi brad welcome to
the show
thanks dave
we're dead free as of last year we have
a decent income we have four kids but uh
one of them is currently sleeping in our
closet we desire to move buy some land
and build a house later we're
considering buying a particular lot that
recently became available that we've
been kind of eyeing and waiting on
and we're thinking about purchasing it
with that and paying it off quickly
what would you recommend pass on it or
go for it
i'm a little confused how is that going
to keep the kid from sleeping in the
closet if you want a lot
uh it won't but gradually over time
we'll
we will uh build and move the kid into a
room
why don't you just buy a house that has
a room
we could
y'all want to build brad is that like a
dream like you want to build your own
home
yes
but it feels like you have a more
immediate problem than your solution is
providing
um we've put each child as they've gone
gotten older into the closet and then we
moved them into the room with the others
as we were paying off our house and
unwilling to go into a larger house just
to satisfy getting them a bigger room
so eventually so the kid's in the closet
though because he's like in a pack and
play
type of thing and then when he gets
older for a bed you he has a room he can
go to he will share with the sibling so
it's not yeah you're just saying it kind
of as a joke like
i mean
yes as a joke matters are necessary to
move the child
for the other child that they could go
into that's with the others okay so we
don't have a five-year-old sleeping in
the closet
no no no no no it's a packing plate
dave took it literal and i took it off
it was literal he said he had a kid in
the closet okay
so okay so if you do that if the child
grows up leaves the pack and play moves
in with a sibling in a reasonable
bedroom normal human beings do that
that's fine uh and then you start
building a house and uh within how many
years are you going to be living in the
house the new house
how many years until we move in is that
what you have yeah what's your plan um
within three years the house should be
completed and we should have enough to
to uh pay it off
okay no problem
that shouldn't be a problem i mean i
don't know why you could i mean if you
can buy the land and uh build the house
and be in it within three years that
that shouldn't be an issue
what's the scary part
uh the scary part is we don't have cash
for all of the land purchase unless we
sold our house and made some
some unusual move which would probably
leave you silent again like buying an rv
selling our house and living in it while
we build with cash
so you're asking is it okay to take out
a loan
to get the to get the lot
correct yeah
i you know you can
um
you're just adding debt to your
situation and anytime you add debt to
your situation you destabilize your
situation even more
so i'm trying to think would we we would
not do that and so if i wouldn't do it
what do i what would i tell you i would
do
um but how does that come into play with
the mortgage i know yeah it well you got
you just added debt so what i would do
is i would sell your current home and
move to a rental
not an rv move into a rental and take
the money from your home buy the lot get
a construction loan and start
construction now you've got one mortgage
and you're renting until your house is
completed instead of a home mortgage and
a lot mortgage
and waiting on all that i would not keep
piling up the debt like that so that's
and that's actually the kind of thing
that we did do
sharon and i many years ago
um and so
yeah that that's how i would go at that
uh no i would not just buy the lot and
no i would not live in an rv and no i
would not stay there in a cramped
situation i would be making plans to
move to something else but you can rent
something
for the yeah y'all did that for three
two years we did and that got us into
the home that you grew up in then is
what it amounts to we were there 13
years and then in the next property um
that that um
uh i mean you were like six or seven
when we moved in you left you left for
college you left work or you never lived
in another house yeah we lived in the
rental
for first grade through third grade my
first three third grade and then moved
no that's right and then um but you left
there and went to college and never oh
yeah never never lived in another one of
our houses again so that's that's
that's how we did it in other words it
worked for us and it lasted
the move and it was a nice home it was a
good home good home for the kids to grow
up in all right uh ben is in dayton ohio
hi ben how are you
i'm loan how are you better than i
deserve what's up
well i wanted to uh first start off by
saying that my wife and i are 25
and we're on baby step seven thanks to
your tools so thanks to you and the team
for all the help congrats ben
good job
well thanks um just i'll keep it brief
so i can respect your time uh for funny
money investing or investing that's less
than 10 percent of your net worth uh
what is your opinion on two times and
three times leveraged s p 500 index
funds i don't borrow money so i don't
leverage anything
no i'm sorry not not borrowing money
like a leveraged account but um
like an index fund that mimics two times
what the actual index
does oh oh oh oh oh okay
um i thought you were leveraging into
this fund okay no no sir wouldn't borrow
money again okay all right good then
we're back on the same page
i mean if it's a small amount you want
to play with it that's fine um
i've not used that vehicle personally so
i can't tell you one way or the other
about that part of it but if it's
something you've researched and you feel
fine about and like you said it's less
than 10 of your overall thing it's like
buying a stock i don't buy stock
but if you want a single stocks but if
you want to buy a single stock and it's
less than 10 of your overall net worth
it's not going to affect you if it
evaporates and so it's fine to go ahead
and try something like that at that
point
um but
it's um it's
here's the thing you want to always do
okay
you never want to look
for a get rich quick vibe
on an investment
he who hastens to be rich will not go
unpunished and everyone who's trying to
find a shortcut
everyone who's trying to get an angle my
wife always called it when i was doing
it she said you're scheming and scamming
you know stop that
just be steady just be steady you don't
have to be super boring and just do a cd
that's not what i'm talking about but
any time that if if you catch your and i
i can still do it to this day and i
teach this stuff i have to catch my
spirit and if my spirit is looking for
um a cheat code
for investing you know uh there's a way
to get here that it's a little easier
it's a little faster and it's i and and
and then you start to ignore the things
that are gonna
and you're gonna get yourself in a pinch
and i've seen wealthy people make
themselves poor doing that
because they they keep looking for that
angle they keep looking for the quick
the quick hit
and as long as you're not doing it with
that spirit that's a spirit that's not a
it's not a math thing that's a way you
feel about something
and that's my biggest problem when
people are doing a lot of these weird
investing things that they do uh just
because it's fattish and it's big on the
internet and some stupid reddit thread
or something like that this is the
ramsey show
[Music]
chaos
that's what it can feel like when your
business is growing so fast you've
outgrown your financial and accounting
software the faster you grow the more
likely you are to lose control of the
numbers and here's the reality if you
don't know your numbers you don't know
your business that's why we use netsuite
by oracle the number one cloud financial
system over 28 000 companies use
netsuite by oracle including ramsey
solutions because netsuite gives us a
single view of everything we need to
make daily decisions whether you're
making a few million to hundreds of
millions a year netsuite gives you the
visibility and control of the things you
need to grow like your financials
inventory hr planning budgeting and more
all in one dashboard go to netsuite.com
ramsey right now to get their free
whitepaper jumpstart your cfo career
[Music]
[Applause]
rachel cruz ramsey personality is my
co-host today here on the ramsey show
the new rachel cruz wallet is in and uh
it hasn't quite sold out yet has it nope
few left but it is a
a limited quantity that we did on this
so it's not going to stay around forever
but
what's the color rachel's favorite
champagne
if they had a color called pizza you
would you it's beautiful
shines glistens oh i mean it's it's
awesome so yes so this wallet has um
envelopes that are sewn in so you get
five or six depending on how you kind of
look at it uh envelopes for your
categories for your cash there's ten
card slots for debit cards insurance
cards gift cards all that's membership
cards
a place to put your change if you want
that
a wrist slit that we added which is
beautiful oh
real leather and we partnered with join
a company or a nonprofit out of india
and they employ people that were coming
out of really hardship type situations
and giving them trade and skill and now
they can work which is awesome too so
it's just a beautiful beautiful product
which i'm so excited about make a joke
about the slots being a little bigger
for the money for inflation
we added a little extra room
this is the inflationary one
we did not go up on the price though did
we
uh no no we didn't okay so we we we're
not participating in inflation yes
so it's
it's awesome so yeah i you know my
my thought behind this whole wallet was
i was like you know i had the envelopes
and i had like clips
that i did for so long and put the only
my own wallet that i liked versus like
paper envelopes and all that
and i thought why don't we just create
one and
anyways very excited about it so the new
company has joined uh it's a very high
quality product yes genuine leather
everything yep it um you know it does
fit for international women's month here
so there you go
the new rachel cruz wallet check it out
uh at ramseysolutions.com
how much are we selling if you smell it
nope i can't smell it i love it i love
it all right favorites
it changes so just go to go to
ramsolutions.com and the prices change
the store yeah just change them every
day or whatever smell it selling
smelling out fast
smelling out fast
okay there you go
broadcast excellence all right this
smell it smells wonderful so fyi our
question of the day comes from
blinds.com they have a 100 satisfaction
guarantee that means even if you
mismeasure you pick the wrong color
they'll remake your blinds for free free
samples free shipping and with the new
promos they run every month you'll save
even more use the promo code ramsey to
get the best possible deal and today's
question comes from norman in louisiana
this question has been a big debate in
our home after reading your book my
fiance and i have two loans to pay a
student loan around 28 000 currently at
zero percent interest and a car loan
around twenty thousand with zero percent
interest for the life of the loan
i think the student loan should be paid
off first to take advantage of the zero
interest since the auto loan has no
interest at all after reading your book
my fiance says paying off the auto loan
first is the right way to go given the
two loans what would you recommend
paying off the auto loan
or i'm sorry would you still recommend
paying the auto
loan off first utilizing the snowball
method neither you should not be paying
each other's debts you're not married
you jumped in that's what i was gonna
say
[Laughter]
oh sorry so yeah i mean yeah you're at
this point because you're not married
you guys should not be combining money
so paying on your own is the way it goes
so let's just pretend though norman that
both of these loans are yours
then yes the debt snowball method is the
way to go so it would be paying off the
car loan first so
in the mathematical sense your fiance is
correct but depending on again
whose loan or loans they are is the
person that should be paying because you
i mean you've done this obviously longer
than i have
the horror stories of of even engaged
couples with the intent of getting
married but you're paying on people you
know you're you're spending your savings
on the fiance's debt and then you end up
not getting married it's and it just
turns out we have just the other day
that the person died in the middle and
they were married and they had the house
together and now he owns a house with
her mother
i mean he owns a house with her father
i'm sorry his fiancee died in a car
wreck oh and um
and they bought a house together and so
now he and his he and her father
own the house together this is and talk
about awkward and horrible in a bad
situation and all that so no you do not
combine money until you're married and
you do not buy things together until
you're married with both of his name on
it because you're creating a partnership
in a legal sense a general partnership
and unless you have full-on partnership
documents that what occurs if one of you
dies or is disabled or whatever you get
yourself in a real mess here so but back
to the question let's pretend you were
married and these loans were just there
and back to the argument about the zero
percent the zero percent the zero
percent the zero percent doesn't matter
what matters is you need to get stinking
loans paid off
both of them as soon as possible
and so there and they're both if you
lean into it they're both going to be
paid off so fast that the interest rate
or the lack of an interest rate is not
relevant
mathematically it's not going to create
that much and so yeah you get the car
loan paid off as quick as you can
because it's the smallest debt and then
you pay off the student loan as fast as
you can because it's the next smallest
debt that's assuming they're both that
that's assuming you were married or both
of them were one of you like yours
norman as an example that kind of a
thing mike's with us in tampa hey mike
welcome to the ramsay show
hey dave how are you thank you for
taking my call i really appreciate it
sure um
i have been listening to you guys now
for about a month and i am absolutely
hooked i'm on a travel nursing
assignment here in miami so i have
nothing better to do with my free time
but listen to you guys my wife i'm
trying to get on board with everything
and the
thought of us getting out of debt is
scaring her to death
however with that being said
um last year we sold our home and we
were able to profit around sixty
thousand dollars on the sale of the home
we spent ten thousand on some debt and
we have fifty thousand dollars
sitting in our savings account hopefully
ready to put a down payment on another
home we have a friend of ours a mutual
friend of ours that is trying to
convince us and i'm not for or against
it i just don't know i'm very neutral on
it trying to convince us to move that 50
000
out of our
account as soon as we can and put it
into precious levels to protect
or lose but to protect it from anyone
that might be trying to come in and
steal it from us if you will from our
check and savings account um what do you
got to be kidding me
this guy's a conspiracy theorist from
now on isn't he like sounds like my
friends
just kidding again again i don't know
very neutral
he's gone down he's gone down the rabbit
hole with alice in wonderland i mean
there's just the chances of somebody
stealing your 50 000 out of a checking
account out of a bank in the united
states of america is very close to zero
that's absurd okay that's crazy that's
crazy talk
i mean and the chances of you losing
your butt putting this into precious
metals is very high
it's a good chance you're gonna lose
your butt and so really really bad
advice any other advice this guy gives
you don't take it either because he's
got he's really bad at advice
so are you are you talking about buying
a home here in the us you're u.s
citizens or what i'm hearing the accent
uh yes uh um i'm a green card holder i'm
of course eligible to to purchase a home
um
but um you know we have a little bit of
debt that we
we
need to pay off cars and um 401k loan
and such but um we were wondering should
we um you know save the fifty thousand
dollars to put down on the home before
we
get out of our vehicles and stuff like
that or do we should we take the fifty
thousand and put that on our vehicles
and then try to cash flow on the home or
just again how much debt do you have
um
so i would say probably 60 probably 70
000 and what's your household income
um about
it's difficult to say right now but
probably this year i'm probably
scheduled to make about
120 great okay what we would tell you to
do is to become debt free as soon as
possible
build an emergency fund of three to six
months of expenses and then build up
your down payment which will be fairly
easy to do when you don't have any
payments anymore
so no precious metals under any
circumstances
yes pay off debt
become debt free it is the shortest
distance between where you are in
becoming wealthy appreciate you
listening mike don't listen to this guy
anymore he's not smart
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
if you're considering a career in
technology i recommend bethel tech and
i'm not alone here's what brendan said
before bethel tech i was driving uber
within four months of graduating i got a
job paying sixty thousand dollars about
two years after that i got a remote job
that pays me a hundred and thirty
thousand dollars all thanks to what i
learned at bethel tech you could be next
get started today at bethel
betheltech.net
and get one thousand to twenty five
hundred dollars off of your tuition
again it's betheltech.net
ken coleman
[Music]
rachel cruz ramsey personality is my
co-host today
open phones at eight eight two five five
two two five in the lobby of ramsey
solutions on the debt free stage amy is
with us hi amy how are you good how are
you guys doing doing great doing great
where do you live battle creek michigan
battle creek michigan home of kellogg's
right yes yeah i love it very cool
welcome to nashville and here to do a
debt free scream how much did you pay
off 39
992.58
very cool how long did this take you
nine months and eight days all right and
your range of income during that time no
range just seventy three thousand
dollars straight up what do you do for a
living i'm a forensic chemist and crime
scene responder
oh
interesting
so you're called in
yes for all the crime scenes wow
that's an intense job girl good for you
amy there might be some crime podcast
junkies in this building and they might
be sitting near me
some in there too
amy can give us everything but amy what
an incredible job yeah wow incredible so
what kind of debt was your 40 000 the
first half was a car a treadmill and two
credit cards and a refrigerator this
second half was a heloc that i took out
due to murphy visiting before i was
quite ready oh
okay
so um
something happened nine months ago what
was the wake-up call what made you do
this ramsay stuff cause you went after
it when you went uh 2020 happened
there's that yeah
yeah so prefer
professionally our homicide rate tripled
in our city
but
personally i had um other than that the
pandemic did not really impact me at all
but in january i started out the new
year with monotonsilitis and pinkeye in
both eyes at the same time
in february my doctor told me that due
to a chronic health condition that i've
had since i was 16 he did not believe
i'd ever have kids
my furnace broke my air conditioner
broke i was diagnosed with skin cancer
and then
my neighbor's tree fell on my house good
lord it's a country song
yeah wow it's a lot it was a lot um it
was a lot at work with just being busy
but it was personally very overwhelming
well and you you know these these uh
i mean you're a professional you're
going to these scenes but that's a lot
too for to see that much more tragedy
yes with the homicide rate increasing so
on top of that all these personal things
boom boom boom boom boom boom boom and
you just said
i got to get rid of the debt i mean how
does debt come up out of all of that
mainly because there was nothing i could
control in 2020 except for my finances
so after the skin cancer diagnosis
of the week of christmas i finally said
2020 was out of my control and the only
thing i could control was my money and
so i i bought the total money makeover
i signed up for fpu in january and by
the time the class finished in march i
was completely debt free of everything
except for
that heloc which i had not yet drawn on
but due to the damage of the house it
totaled fifty thousand dollars and
the contractor had came to me and said
insurance hasn't paid enough and so we
need you to start paying and then once
we finish the job
you'll get reimbursed so i maxed out the
heloc at twenty thousand dollars and
then the insurance actually declined his
final invoice
so i was on the hook and so i was
gazelle intense for the first three
months to pay off the original consumer
debt and then i had to restart that
gazelle intensity in may oh that's what
you meant by the first and the second
half yeah so i kind of had a pause
because i anticipated getting paid back
everything and when i did not why did
they deny his invoice um they had agreed
to pay quite a bit of money but
they insurance had said that
basically he did upgrades to the house
that they didn't approve of so it was
simple things as far as switching from
aluminum siding was no longer available
so he switched it to vinyl which was a
lot cheaper and they didn't agree with
that
so um i was on the hook for a lot more
money than i anticipated so my gazelle
intensity had to restart in may in order
for me to finish by october then wow so
what was that like i mean was it i mean
i'm sure devastating yeah that's a kick
but then like what did you feel like you
were just you kind of put your anger and
your frustration towards that process
yes it was a lot it was overwhelming as
far as
the roofing shingles of course they were
out of stock and didn't have what
insurance would cover so i had to pay
more to get what was in stock
choosing the siding color choosing the
whole inside which some of my pictures
showed
the drywall on the interior
was all wet so they had to rip out
several sections of drywall and replace
it all all the light fixtures needed to
be replaced so it was a lot of decision
making that being single and um that was
all on me to decide so it was just a
basically eight months of a lot of
construction and just overwhelming how's
your health right now how are you doing
health-wise because that's a lot of
health stuff you had too yes um doing
all right yeah got it got it
wow
you're incredible yeah you've come
through a lot this is a i mean the forty
thousand dollars in debt pales to
comparison and everything else you've
done i mean that's amazing so very well
done well done you're a warrior warrior
woman no question about it good stuff
okay in the middle of all of this uh oh
um this was your insurance company
yes okay
have you contacted an attorney
uh no i i talked to my contractor i
think a lot of it too was
miscommunication between the two of them
so i did spend a good month fighting to
get some of the money back but not all
of it and a lot of it was just due to a
lack of communication between the
contractor and the adjuster during the
process
i'm so sorry yeah i think i'm getting a
different insurance company too yeah
changing my homeowners insurance for
sure
and i'm tempted to ask you who it was
but i'm going to leave it alone
insurance
no i know but i mean i just she's been
pooped on by an insurance company so
it's true it's unbelievable i can't
stand insurance companies anyway so oh
my gosh wow
way to go well in spite of them yeah you
you fought through it all and you're
amazing you're a hero i usually ask
what's the hardest part but there's a
lot of whole thing
i don't want to ask that question what
do you tell people the key to getting
out of debt is um i wrote this down so
sacrifice and ownership like i said
earlier there's so much out of my
control but finances were part of
something i could control and so once i
took responsibility where i was in life
was my choice i was in debt and that was
when my decisions that i had made and
once i took responsibility and ownership
of that it was a lot easier to sacrifice
i think the hardest part for me was i
traveled a lot to see my family they
live a couple hours away
and so i cut that out
so that's the hardest part for me was to
not go in and see them but
yeah it was a lot easier to make the
sacrifices that i needed to once i took
that responsibility yeah yeah so who are
your biggest cheerleaders
my twin sister over here is my
accountability partner all right and my
mom who actually would send me uh stuff
in the mail with a little little cash to
go get that you know pop that you i know
you can't afford and
um so yeah they were definitely big
motivators for me i love it that's great
i love it well done well you're a hero
i'm proud of you thank you great work
really great work we got a copy of baby
steps millionaires that's the next
chapter in your story you can fight
through this you can fight through
anything and uh when you take it you
know put the shoulders back like that
and say it's my responsibility that's a
big part of the whole healing process so
very very well done very well done also
a copy of total money makeover which
started the whole thing for you and you
can give that away to somebody and go
this is how i did it this is how i paid
off 40 000 in nine months in spite of
all the unbelievable year that you've
had wow pretty cool all making seventy
three thousand all right amy from battle
creek michigan she did it
she's a warrior forty thousand dollars
paid off in nine months making 73. count
it down let's hear a debt-free scream
three two one i'm daddy
[Applause]
i
love it she has like such this like
sweet calming voice i was like i wonder
what her debt free screams gonna be man
she did it i love it
oh man well with what she's been through
she deserves a belt of a scream
absolutely absolutely amazing so the
moral of the story is make sure your
contractor and your insurance company
are working together i know
start breaking ouch
ouch that is so that is like life though
right you
it crawls up but we talk about too
sometimes the baby steps some of the
most defeating things when you have to
go back and forth like because life
happens right and it's one of those but
i love that she just still
grinded it like it's like okay this is
happening and i'm gonna do it
i mean she and sacrificed the numbers
too on this oh man she kicked it pretty
incredible
it's awesome it's pretty amazing
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
our scripture today proverbs 17 22 a
cheerful heart is good medicine
but a crushed spirit dries up the bones
tom landry said confidence comes from
knowing what you're doing if you're
prepared for something you usually do it
if not you usually fall flat on your
face
well that would be true
rachel cruz ramsey personality is my
co-host today as we answer your
questions about your life and your money
joanne is in west palm beach hi joanne
welcome to the ramsay show
hey dave and rachel thank you so much
for all you do for us people and
i am feeling so blessed that you took my
call today well we're honored how can we
help wonderful
okay so
i'm 62 years old and
i got some problems i i am in about 80
000
in debt
of with 17
500 his car
31 000 is he locked and 29 000 is credit
card
i am a christian
i want to pay my bills i don't want to
make anybody
i don't want to screw anyone over i
i'm just having a hard time and
by the way i have 33 13 000 cash i've
been saving some cash because
um
there's a lot of wonkiness going on in
our world today and
i'm scared i'm i'm frightened i'm very
frightened and i lived past
the 2008 debacle
which almost made me homeless but the
lord
my lord jesus christ
sent me someone who helped me get
a loan modification
god is so
what's your household income
my household income is wonky because i'm
in sales
last year i made 58 000 but this year i
i see that when i'm making now i'm on
track to make ten thousand dollars less
and i think it's because people are
afraid to spend money
well they're spinning like crazy on some
things
so how old are you
i'm i'm going i'm going to be 63 in in
june and
i know i'm never going to be able to
retire
because i don't have all but just this
13 000 in cash
so i just want to do what's best
okay
all right
well what we would tell you is that you
can retire uh you're not gonna retire
soon
but um
and if i'm in your shoes i'm gonna get
really geared up on my sales job and
instead of taking a ten thousand dollar
less i'm gonna make ten thousand dollars
more
uh because i'm gonna get geared up with
some serious goals and start plowing my
way through this debt so that i can
start investing so i have a nest egg and
if you did that for the next uh i don't
know six five six seven years i think
you not only would be debt free
have an emergency fund but you also
could have have the beginnings of an
estate you're not going to be worth
millions of dollars but you could get
really really stable but it's going to
require a lot of hard work and diligence
on your part to do that
and so the way we teach people to do
that is called the baby steps
uh we'll send you a copy of the book the
total money makeover to show you how to
do those but rachel i think she can do
it
oh absolutely and joanne it's gonna
sound like a little bit of a mind
shift though for you because
you have a lot of credit card debt which
says something to me right i don't know
if you're spending money
just to acquire i don't know if this is
to help pay your bills i don't know what
that credit card debt is but there's a
lot there you have 17 000 car loan you
could sell the car and reduce some of
this debt by just doing that
um and looking but but the way you've
been living just by the numbers you've
given me it's a little bit all over the
place and it doesn't feel extremely
sharp and organized so
like like dave just said i'm like i
would take on an extra job
your job in sales that's right have the
mindset of like hey i'm gonna make more
this year not less i'm not gonna settle
for anything more and you go in and make
a larger income this year
and then you're going to tighten up your
budget and you're going to start working
your way out of this debt and it's going
to take a lot of intentionality
strictness
and even from your voice you sound so
kind joanne so kind
um but i want you to be a little bit
more uh
on your money and in your situation you
know what i mean a little bit of a
little bit of grit in there
to have some level of forward motion
into the baby steps um but again don't
give up i mean the age i understand can
be defeating
um because you feel like you're 62 and
you just have your 13 000 and that's it
but if you start working this process
it's going to take a little bit but you
can see progress i think you can be debt
free and have a hundred thousand two
hundred thousand dollars in the bank in
seven years
uh but you're going to make more and
you're going to be be very very diligent
list your we're going to teach you baby
step one's a thousand dollars so uh
wonkiness in the world or not i'm gonna
have a thousand dollars set aside i'm
gonna put 12 000 towards your smallest
debts listing your debts smallest to
largest and that's probably those credit
cards uh they're probably individual
cards it's probably not one twenty nine
thousand dollar card so we're going to
list those out and we're going to use
that 12 000 towards those smallest ones
we're going to cut them all up and we're
going to get on a budget living on a
plan and working the plan working the
plan working the steps working the plan
working the steps and again we'll show
you how to do that with the total money
makeover book and if you'll get you just
use that as this is the process this is
what we do this is the process nothing
else this is the process i've got to
work the plan i've got to work the plan
then you'll be able to push through and
get moving in the right direction so hey
good call thank you for joining us
brayden is with us in tulsa hi brayden
welcome to the ramsay show
hi dave how are you doing good man
what's up
good um
i
just have a concern i feel
kind of like
my my wife and i are drowning
um
we
have a two-year-old and we're expecting
another
baby in october you are drowning
congrats brayden that's awesome man
thank you that's great but wow what a
house full of what a house full of
there's a lot going on here
definitely um on to the drowning part
um my last night she's a teacher i just
work part-time because i'm trying to go
to school full-time
and we make about fifty thousand dollars
a year
and
um
that turns out to be about
thirty six hundred dollars a month
and
we have a thousand dollar mortgage
payments we
budget 400 for groceries and our total
debt payments are about a thousand
um
we have
10 000 on credit card debt
um 24 000 in student loans that are
paying on that now
ten thousand and card loans
and
all of that
just
um leaves us with very minimal oh yeah
you got no room in this budget
yeah so uh when do you graduate
i graduate in
um
let's see fall 2023
so in a year and a half basically in
what
in human resources management okay
um
you got a tough 18 months ahead of you
you got a lot going on babies young
marriage debt coming out your ears your
house payment's too big
your other debts are too big yeah you
are overwhelmed i don't blame you i get
it i see how you feel drowning um but
you're gonna you're gonna work
an extra job a lot more than you are now
you've got to get your income up or
something's gonna have to give
and the something may be selling the
house it may be selling the car it may
be selling both of them
but the numbers you're giving me are not
sustainable
that's why you feel like you're drowning
okay
yeah we have ten thousand for two cars
so my wife and i both have a car yeah
okay you've not got not got super
expensive cars but but a thousand dollar
house payment on a 30 600 take home pay
is not sustainable
now you can you can you can do that for
18 months but you're going to have to be
door dashing and and delivering pizzas
and some other stuff you are going to
have a a bizarre schedule you all are
going to be exhausted within this 18
months but at least then you'll be able
to go get a job making 50 or 60 000
bucks stay in the flow for the 18 months
if you can hang on
do something ridiculous to hang on for
the 18 months and get out the other side
you can make it but
you're not even going to make it 18
months with what you got right in front
of you something's going to give hang on
we're going to put you through financial
peace university is our gift that puts
us hour the ramsey show
in the books we'll be back with you
before you know it in the meantime
remember there's ultimately only one way
to financial peace and that's to walk
daily with the prince of peace hey it's
british co-host on the ramsay show if
you want to do your debt free stream
live on the show visit
ramseysolutions.com
debt free screen we'd love for you to
come to nashville and tell dave your
story that's
ramseysolutions.com debt free screen
[Music]
you